hey it's a Sunday and the Sunday means
that I answer all of your questions so
I'm on my youtube channel now I'm gonna
read through find some niggling property
questions that you've had and do my best
to answer those right now
if you have a niggling property question
that's not answered or if i answer one
question and it shoots another question
to mine please do comment your question
below I'll do my best to answer next
week also I put out a video a new video
every single day and this is the only
day of the week where I do this so if
you haven't subscribed to the channel
please do subscribe and turn on the
notifications but you don't miss the
awesome contest to come out and please
don't forget to smash that like button
as well it really helps with the
algorithm I appreciate that so let's get
some of these questions answered let's
see what we got so choline and discern
but she says has I'm a great video
question for the next Q&A which is this
one when doing direct to vend or letters
landlord letters which VA system do you
recommend using for calls as I worked
flat out and wouldn't be able to answer
calls as and when they come through
thanks no that's great question and I'm
fact that you asked that question too
shows that you're on the right page so
firstly landlord letters are fantastic
so that's when you send out a letter doe
rec to someone that's selling their
house a landlord or an owner and the
thing is as Colleen said is when you
send out a letter huge butt contact at
the bottom of the letter otherwise they
won't get in touch with you but if
you're really busy then your contact
number they might phone you and your mr.
cool so what I do is I have or now I
have staff and stuff but what I started
doing in the early days is I had a
personal assistant and virtual assistant
you can get these free lamps so I use a
company called I'm your PA and Michelle
M she's a really good friend of mine and
also she's a chichi
she was of the agency for many years
she's got company and they can literally
buy you can buy like a number so if
you're sending letters landlord letters
to Middlesbrough you can buy and
Middlesbrough local landline number and
then when they call that landline number
Michelle and her team will answer the
phone and they'll take a message
and then they'll text you or email you
and then what that means is the end of
each day five o'clock you can just check
Europe your phone check your emails
you've got all these people to phone
back and bambam bam-bam-bam
you can learn more at once so it's a
really good set up so a good job glad
you're sending the letters glad you take
an action and hope that little tip helps
with the power team and if you want to
you can meet my whole power team and any
of our advanced training that we do we
introduce you to mortgage brokers
solicitors personal assistants people
that evening
new properties on your behalf so let's
see what else we've got
and the bow with a dough right said
would you buy a flat in a building are
they not good investments because they
sold leasehold thank you I really enjoy
your videos Thank You Annabelle Phoebe a
question so yeah I would buy a flat
I don't massively advocate flats because
the problem with flats that I found one
problem is that they are you get a
service charge so ground rent service
charge because the thing is with an
apartment or a flat you own the the flat
but you don't own the building that it's
in and building the good thing about
that is the building is maintained by
someone else apart from you but you have
to pee
annual charge for that and you don't
know what that charge can be and it can
change so sometimes it's difficult
working out the return on investment
also flat I found that they don't go up
much in value I think that when friends
you know the series the friends when
that came out was that in the back end
of the 80s early 90s maybe apartments
became really popular
everyone wanted an apartment because
they wanted to be liked what they saw
and friends New York apartments went
crazy London apartments went crazy but
when I started buying apartments in 2008
they've not gone up anywhere near as
much as houses have gone up so but yeah
I would buy them they're not terrible if
the return investment is good if you're
going to make money on them no problem
I'd rather buy the building and then
turn it into apartments and just buy an
apartment now generally speaking and yes
you're right they are leasehold and that
just means that you don't own the ground
you just own the apartment so yeah pub
answers your question not terrible not
brilliant depends on from property to
property david says questions for you do
you think a communal lounge area is
necessary in an HMO property very
interested to hear thoughts no it's not
necessary so if the bedrooms are 100
square feet which is a good double sized
bedroom you do not need a communal area
and what I've noticed you've HMOs is
that the tenants don't use the communal
area that often so as long as the
bedrooms are a hundred square feet each
which is just a decent double size room
you don't need one if they're less than
that then the bedroom all HMOs the
bedrooms need to be at least 270 square
feet if it's if it's more than 70 but
less than 100 you will need a communal
Harry so I usually find in HMOs and
annoyingly what happens is one or two
tenants
- almost claim the communal area and
they're in it all the time and no one
else really use it so these days I've
been buying houses and having slightly
bigger bedrooms no communal area no TV
you don't need a TV in HMO they just use
their laptops and their phones so I hope
that helps
David all right Adam hi Samuel I
appreciate the great work boom thanks
Adam
we're just wondering when you sell a
deal on to another investor is there a
v80 on top of the finder's fee also is
there income tax on top that okay really
important v80 you cannot charge v80
unless you are v80 registered otherwise
you would be breaking the law because
that is if you're VAT registered you
have to pay that on everything and
that's why people that are about
registered will charge a battle top so
you don't need to be back registered you
have to check with an accountant I think
it's 86,000 pounds but let's say 80 to
be safe if you earn less than if your
company earns less than 80 thousand
pound or you earn less than 80 thousand
pound you don't need to be about
register you don't need to pay that and
you shouldn't be charging for that so
income tax no you shouldn't charge
income tax on top of a fee that's just
just something that you have to pay if
you want to do that then just put your
prices up but you wouldn't have it as a
separate billing so hope that helps
great question thank you for that
okay let's see what else we got nella
says can you get a lease option
agreement even if your credit score is
low yes you can you don't need a good
credit score to get a lease option
agreement what you should be mindful of
though it's at the end of the lease
option agreement let's say is 5 or 10
years that's when you'll have the option
to buy the house I would be wanting to
get your credit sorted by the time the
lease option agreement ends so you can
buy but you don't have to and you can
walk away at the end of the period or
you can even transfer it on to somebody
else as long as it's all written up
properly by a solicitor okay Dave if
you're doing a rent to rent how do you
check if the existing landlords mortgage
allows you to do rent to rent as in the
eyes of the mortgage company you're
effectively subletting
okay so rent around needs to be done
properly how do you know if the mortgage
gives you permission to rent it out
let's say you're doing a you're turning
a single dwelling into a multi let how
do you how do you know if the mortgage
company it gives you permission to do it
like that you just need to ask the
question you just need to make sure that
the landlord if the landlord has a
mortgage company that he informs the
company of what he's doing it's really
simple you won't you won't speak to the
to the mortgage lender you'll do it all
through the owner but you'll have to
tell the owner what you're doing and
make sure that he's happy and he has no
mortgage company so we've got we have
got war I think that's probably what
we've got time for this evening so if
you've got more questions and you want
to hear the answers next week just drop
a comment in below drop a question in
below I love doing this every single
Sunday don't forget we have videos every
single day so subscribe never miss a
video
look forward to seeing you rich success